Okay,
quick question.
Are you a Christian?
I suppose the most straightforward
answer to that is yes.
Although I think it's.
Let's leave it at.
Yes.
I'm a bit dissatisfied with that because
there are so many kinds of Christians.
Christian,
well,
there are.
There are truths to other than the
literal that perhaps are more truthful
than even literal truth.
No.
There are many kinds of truth and I
don't mean that in A.
I don't mean that in a postmodern way
actually,
but the truths that govern behavior and
the truths that emerged from facts are
not the same truths.
What do you do you believe that Jesus
rose again from the day I find it.
I cannot answer that question and the
reason is because.
Let me think about it for a minute.
See if I can come up with a reasonable
answer to that.
Well,
the first answer would be it depends on
what you mean by Jesus and historical
human being that existed in a.
It was a physical body and then it was
on earth that was literally was
literally came back to life after death.
I would say that at the moment I'm
agnostic about that issue,
which is a lot different than saying I
don't believe for it's happened.
Explain why when I get to that,
when I get to the New Testament,
in my biblical lectures,
I'll spend like six hours trying to
explain what I think about that,
but one of the things I have come to
learn over the last 15 years in
particularly in particular is that the
world is a theory,
theory,
strange place.
It's far stranger than we think and what
we don't understand about consciousness
and its relationship with the body was
still many books and you could say the
same thing about our relationship with
time and perhaps corporality and
vulnerability and all and death for that
matter.
So I don't understand that.
The structure of being well enough to to
to make my way through the complexities
of the resurrection story.
I would say it's the most mysterious
element of the biblical stories to me
and perhaps I'm not alone,
is now.
I mean it's the central.
It's the central drama and in the
Christian Corpus,
let's say,
but I don't believe that it's reasonable
to boil it down to something like,
do you believe that or do you not
believe that?
You know it's not.
It's I don't know what the limits.
I don't know the limits of human
possibility.
I don't know intriguing because I had
very much has you down as somebody sold
us essentially projections of the human
consciousness.
They are that and I could say I could
say the death and resurrection of Jesus
Christ symbolizes the necessity of the
psyche to a sequence of deaths and
rebirths attainment of the ideal.
That's what I expected you to say is
true.
It's a phoenix.
It's a phoenix story.
No know the actual facts.
It started.
The thing is is that just because that's
true,
it doesn't mean that's all true about it
because I also don't know.
So here,
for example,
in order to stay alive,
it's necessary to get the balance
between death and life are in your
psyche and your physiology because that
keeps you alive.
Your cells die and regenerate all the
time,
and if you die too much,
then you die,
and if you don't die enough,
well then you also die.
You end up with cancer or something like
that.
You have to get the balance between
death and life,
right?
In order to survive.
I don't know what would happen if you
got the balance between death and life
exactly right and I don't know what the
upper limits are to human possibility
and and neither does anyone else,
and human consciousness and human beings
are capable of.
We don't know what we're capable of,
I suppose is the final answer,
and so I'm unwilling for a variety of
reasons which aren't,
which I can't explain.
They're tangled up with the experiences
of the experiences that I've had that I
can't.
I can't.
I can neither understand newer
explained,
but I'm unwilling to rule out.
I'm unwilling to rule out the existence
of heaven.
of life after death.
I'm unwilling to rule out the idea of
universal redemption and the defeat of
evil.
Now I know perfectly well that all those
things can be pro well conceptualized
metaphorically.
I know that metaphorical
conceptualization,
but I'm not willing to make the claim
that those ideas exhaust themselves in
the metaphor of it's,
you know,
I'm not in a position as of yet to
articulate why I think that in a manner
that would be anything other than a
jumble of lateral thoughts.
I have thoughts,
but they're not organized and part of
the reason I'm doing the biblical
lecture series is to organize those
thoughts.
That's so interesting.
I had one day I'll have a chance to ask
you more about that.